i need to see this crisis for myself
where will you go
the day after i'm supposed to disappear
i'll come right back to this moment i
promise
what'd you see there kid something's
coming all of our lives are gonna be on
the line welcome to earth one my name is
cisco ramon
oh great people i love
[Music]
what do you want for your universe to
survive
the plent you destroyed it you destroyed
norah's message
unfortunate side effect
but i needed to discourage you from
doing what
hoping your determination is boundless
flash
it is one of your greatest qualities but
you cannot avoid the coming crisis mary
has five years before he vanishes
no longer december 10 2019
on that day he will answer the call
and make the ultimate sacrifice soon
this world will fight for the fate of
all the known universes
i'm not gonna leave my family there has
to be a way to stop what's coming i am
sorry
but events have been set into motion
that you cannot possibly
comprehend i don't need to understand
them
just tell me what i can do to survive
you can't in order for billions to
survive this coming crisis
the flash must die
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my flash season 6 episode
2 trailer video barry going into the
future doing exactly what jay garrick
told him not to do then we finally get
jay garrick back so we'll break it all
down
crisis on infinite earths we're actually
doing a new flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your best theory about the
episode on the video
starting at the beginning here barry
tells iris in the cortex he's time
traveling to the day after
he's supposed to die which according to
the monitor is december 10th
this year that's also supposed to be the
day that the flash episode of the actual
crossover crossovers happening in real
life
the whole thing about the monitor is
that he said that in order for the
multiverse to survive
not only would all the heroes have to
battle for its survival
but it was imperative that the flash die
a lot of you on my episode one video are
like what if they just substitute
another version of barry allen like the
earth 90 version who's played by john
wesley's ship and he sacrifices himself
there's so many people that are trying
to find a way around oliver queen having
to die
but i think that completely circumvents
the whole point of the conversation that
oliver had in the deal he made with the
monitor during last year's crossover
universe is a complex piece of machinery
and balance must be maintained
one change requires another
how would you propose i keep the balance
will you help me
save barry and cara or not no
but i will give you the means to save
them tell me what you need in exchange
whatever the multiverse requires to
survive the crisis
that is looming
when it is time so it just seems clear
right now that they want you to think
that oliver is going to
pull out some big surprise and he will
wind up sacrificing himself and
quote-unquote disappearing
that doesn't necessarily mean that he's
going to die it just means that everyone
thinks that he's going to die
and that there's a gravestone in the
future that doesn't mean that there's a
body
in that gravestone because it makes it
sound like he's going to be doing
something on a more cosmic level after
he eventually quote unquote disappears
but they don't actually show you barry
traveling to the future in the trailer
there is a shot of the particle
accelerator in the previous trailers
exploding but it's at night so you can't
tell if the skies are red and remember
it's crisis soap per that newspaper all
the skies are supposed to be red
that's just a counter measure either
from the reverse flash or from the
anti-monitor or from someone on his team
to block all the powers of the versions
of superman in supergirl
then we see him with jay garrick waking
up with joan looking over him like his
mother
so obviously this is a totally different
person because it seems like they're on
earth 3 based on the way this is all
decorated
and she's not his mother on earth 3 but
she looks exactly like her because she's
an alternate earth virgin
i believe her name in the episode is
joan williams
so she might be married to jay garrick
and just have kept her maiden name but
it looks like she's a scientist
and she's sort of a version of tina
mcgee on this earth like the classic
earth 90 flash had tina mcgee helping
him out with all the science of it all
jay garrix only told us a little bit
about his backstory i got a lot of
questions on one of the previous
trailers as to whether or not they ever
had a son
that looked like barry allen on earth 3
and it sounds like he did not because we
probably would have met that character
already but they
probably don't want to recycle too many
twists because we met a version of barry
allen on earth too so they don't want
every single berry to show up on every
single earth
then there's that crisis on infinite
earth's scene with barry in the time
vault with the monitor telling him
in no uncertain terms there's nothing he
can do he shouldn't try to avoid it
just make your peace with it because you
absolutely have to die in order for the
multiverse to survive
he doesn't say why or how that's going
to happen all we know from the future
newspapers is that it says
flash vanishes in crisis and everyone
assumes that he's dead they just talk
about him like he's dying
the whole reason why he had to do that
in the comics is because the ansi
monitor had created this giant space gun
that he was going to fire
at planet earth completely obliterated
so barry has
to run faster and faster than he ever
has around it to dismantle the weapon
but in doing so he goes so fast that his
body
turns into pure speed force energy and
he seemingly disappears
dying part of the reason they did this
is because they wanted wally west to
become the main version of the flash a
lot of the crisis
comic book in the 1980s was a transition
from the silver age of comics to the
modern age
where a lot of the sidekick heroes or
the younger heroes sort of came into
their own became adults and became the
main versions of those characters in the
comics
so that's where you get to the wally
west era of the comics barry disappeared
into the speed force's pure energy for a
little over 20 years before he returned
during flash rebirth in 2009 pretty safe
bet that those circumstances around him
disappearing are going to be different
for the tv show won't be some giant
space gun it'll be some other reason why
he winds up disappearing
but in the future that he's going to see
during episode 2
oliver probably will have not done
whatever things he's going to do
differently to save barry and prevent
him from disappearing
so the flash showrunner actually posted
this comment
saying that basically we're going as if
barry really is dying everyone's going
to assume that for the rest of the first
half of the season that means in episode
three
four five six so on so forth barry still
thinks that he's going to die so he sort
of goes on his bucket list with a lot of
different team flash members trying to
pass on his knowledge and prepare them
for a world without the flash
as in a world without superman
references if you're a long-time comic
book reader
if you didn't read that world without a
superman is just the story that came
right after they killed superman off
during the death of superman comic book
there's also scenes of barry talking to
the bloodwork villain it seems
a little weird watching this after
watching him freak out while he was busy
getting his powers
usually what happens on the flashes is
that when villains get their powers they
hide it for a little while then they
start to lose control and really turn
into a villain and that's when team
flash gets involved
like it's clear that he has a temper
from his conversation with caitlyn but
he's on this grand
quest to defeat death literally stop
death that makes it sound like he
doesn't care about forcing his cure on
other people
if he could save people what does it
matter he had that whole conversation
with caitlin
even though i didn't mention it in the
video yesterday i've talked about it
during a couple previous videos yes he
is mohinder
from the heroes tv series right now
they're still filming the crossover
episodes
a lot of you were freaking out yesterday
because they posted a behind-the-scenes
picture of them on the wave rider with
grant gustin's flash brandon rouse
kingdom come superman and tyler
heckland's earth 38 superman
but even more people were freaking out
when they saw chris williams black
lightning
posing with grant gustin's flash in a
completely different set this just looks
like an office building
but if you're not sure what's going on
and how this crossover is going to work
and how they're involving black
lightning
yes this does mean now that the black
lightning tv show is officially canon to
the arrowverse whereas before there was
kind of a question mark above it the
showrunner said that he didn't want to
spend too much time trying to cross over
with the arrowverse especially around
last year's crossover like we're doing
our own thing
don't worry about it so you can see most
of those people in the background so if
there was any question
of course this confirms that the legends
will be part of the crossover
but the actual legends of tomorrow
episode of the crossover won't happen
until the second half in january when
the show's come back from the break
and even though you don't see tom
welling's superman in all this he's
probably somewhere in the background too
i'm assuming that his role now based on
the way they talked about it is bigger
than just a single episode cameo
if there are any more crisis teasers or
scenes that drop this week i'll totally
do videos for it leave your requests
in the comments below congratulations
preach ragland you're the giveaway
winner from my last big flash video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so i can get your contact
details
everybody click here for my flash season
6 episode 1 video
and click here for all my joker movie
easter eggs and ending scene
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight
bye